>>Jill: Every week our
students go on some type
of Learning Expedition to
somewhere in our community,
whether students
are on Main Street
and visiting a fire station
and a hair salon to learn
about physical and
chemical changes;
or whether they're studying the
habitats of rain forest animals
at the zoo, the learning
that takes place
in their classroom then comes to
life through these Expeditions.
>>Rachel: We are partnered
with seven museums.
We work with their educators
to help enrich our curriculum
and to find connections
that are natural.
>>Jennifer: We went
to the zoo for one
of our Learning Expeditions.
They offer a lot of
rain forest animals.
And we were able to also
talk about map skills,
as that's a standard
that we need to cover.
They were trying to find
their animal on the map,
understand what rain forest
they were coming from,
why different rain forests have
different types of animals.
>>Rachel: There's a big
difference between a field trip
and a Learning Expedition.
We rarely, if ever, go
through a whole entire museum.
The point for the students
is to go to see the exhibit
that is connected
with the curriculum
that they're studying.
>>Trey: We go, not
only to the museums.
Some of others have been
just community partnerships.
You know, we go to Conasauga
River, it's an opportunity
to work with the
Forestry Service.
And we go snorkeling
at the river there,
we learn about the
diversity of the fishes.
That's a Learning Expedition
that's kind of birthed
out of just the culture of what
can we find in our community
that connects to
what we're learning.
>>Drew: When we go on
the Learning Expedition,
we have people talk to
us about our module,
and they were informed ahead
of time about our module,
and then they can inform
us on what we need to know
and what we haven't learned yet.
>>Maty: I really like going
on the Learning Expeditions,
and getting to interact
with the actual things.
Like when we were on The
Trail of Tears, we got to walk
and experience how it felt.
When we got off the bus, we got
a card with our Cherokee name
and where we lived in Tennessee.
>>Jamie: They went and
talked with a historian
about the passage and learned
about the Cherokee's history
and the decisions that
were faced at that time.
>>Historian: So this is a space
that can also tell us a lot
about Chattanooga's
indigenous past.
That tells us about
the Cherokee.
>>Jamie: They actually went
up to the walking bridge.
One was the land route,
one was the water route.
When they finally got
back to the school,
they opened up their envelopes,
and inside it there was a piece
of paper that said
if they survived
or if they perished
on the trail.
>>Maty: We realized how
hard it must have been,
and like really how hard
the Cherokee had it,
and how terrible it was to
get forced off their lands.
>>Trey: The opportunities
that we have to go outside
of the classroom
are absolutely rich.
Giving the students all the same
experience is where you begin
to now have a discussion.
>>Jill: If you think about a
student who's learning English
as a second language,
or a student who's lived
in a high poverty situation,
who may not have had lots
of these kind of
life experiences.
All of a sudden, they're
going to museums every week.
So their vocabularies
expand, their understanding
of the world expands in
a very significant way.
Over time, what we
basically discovered is
that the world is our classroom.
And that if our students
see learning taking place
everywhere, they become
life-long learners.